[Music]
Dallas Texas
[Music]
what's that is there a fire over there
good morning everybody she's not morning
anymore
um it's also not Christmas anymore we
didn't Vlog during Christmas we didn't
Vlog uh for most of the trip that we're
currently on we're actually in Texas
right now uh visiting my parents what we
are vlogging is our trip today we're
taking my parents Winnebago and we're
gonna go up to Oklahoma so Texas Dallas
Texas to Oklahoma not too far in I think
Durant Oklahoma is like only an hour and
a half or something like that but how
cool is this yeah
Luca knows how to wave now
[Music]
okay all right and then yes I have I do
have a RV uh driving instructor so
that's my RV driving instructor all
right we're gonna do good
that was loud
one of the strangest things about
driving an RV is the fact that you have
to lock down everything that could slide
around including dishes pots pans food
what else is just anything that can kill
you anything that can kill you I'm glad
you did that okay here we go driving my
first time driving in an RV
yeah I'm in Drive okay
get it oh your neighbors are watching me
[Music]
let me see that was on a car crash all
right so before we uh continue on our
journey we're gonna get some breakfast
with the family
hello family and Luca here you're about
to try your first lemon wedge you just
had lemon water for the person oh yeah
so you kind of warmed them up to this
yeah because he's had a lemon flavor
things like oh every time I make avocado
toast for him which is one of his
favorites
are you ready
your first lemon
[Music]
oh you're eating the Rind okay
maybe I should feel it for him
he likes it
he's like all this attention he said yes
in Russian yeah
can you kill it for you hold on let me
feel it okay
I'm making me like yeah my mouth is
salivating right now let's
okay not appeal
foreign
no reaction huh he's a Mexican yeah he
passed the Mexican test look at that
Holy in his mouth chewing am I single
lens or nothing oh there we go there's
something
I love his little mouse movies
not a single reaction look at him
I'm really impressed yeah I'm thoroughly
impressed
because you can eat lemons like that
yeah I can good job baby
you want more
oh
there we go
there we go there's all the lemon juice
I like do we is it even sour no I'm like
what's wrong with it oh no it's
definitely sour
good job oh there we go there's
something
hey the first time I've actually ordered
food for Luca like specifically for him
yeah
protein fiber yeah
[Music]
all right we have made it to the great
state of Oklahoma
[Music]
city of Durant Kevin Durant I wonder
when Kevin Durant oh you don't know
basketball I might yeah I know that he
played for the Oklahoma only whatever it
was so hot
I cheated your mom actually oh I see I
didn't see the um the state line I
didn't see any signs but the that the
Coors Light thing proved that we're in
Oklahoma chill yeah and speaking of
basketball uh earlier this week so we
didn't Vlog very much during this trip
to Dallas in fact it's adding today's
the only day I've actually vlogged I've
been here for a week already I've been
here for a week just wanted to chill
Christmas and a chill just I don't know
see with family without a camera but
since we're doing this road trip I
decided to Vlog but what we did Miss
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Luca to go watch Luca going to a Dallas
Mavericks game that was really fun for
Christmas on Christmas Day Luca's first
Christmas going to his first basketball
game and also my first basketball game
which I found it to be pretty hilarious
that I was wearing all Mavericks here
and not until we got to the game that I
realized that that game we were actually
playing the Lakers so I'm like all right
then I guess I'm going for Dallas but
every time Lakers are scoring I was just
like
Spirit you're like there's a lot of
people around that were wearing like
yeah we were sat in front of a family of
Lakers fans so every time we would have
the Dallas would have the ball they were
behind us they'd be like defense I'm
like that's backwards we're not on
defense and I'm turning around it's like
all purple and gold back there oh okay
then Lakers would be making a I wasn't
making a goal Mickey Clubhouse
technically I'm sleepy I was just taking
a nap in the back he was driving I was
literally laying back there and then
like because the road would be kind of
crazy and so like if this is like
kneeling on the bedroom so like if my
back is on the bed I was like
and then at one point because I was on
the side at one point he was so it was
like so bumpy that I ended up like this
well I just like tossed you around yeah
it was really fun but very dangerous my
dad was like oh yeah I technically she's
not supposed to do that because he's
like he's new to the whole RV game yeah
he's like by the book yeah like these
are the protocols this is such a nice RV
everything's
everything's have like that brand new
car smell too yeah yeah so to explain
our trip this time around we have taken
the RV to Oklahoma and then my brother
drove with Diana and my mom my dad came
with us in here yeah so there's only
four seats there's only four seats in
here yeah so the idea is for them to go
get a hotel which that's where we're
parked in this parking lot they're
checking into the hotel they're gonna
spend the night here and we're gonna
spend a night at a campground but before
we go to sleep tonight we're all gonna
hang out at the ground with this RV
makes some Stakes just enjoy the
amenities because I don't know my dad
and my mom are like super into getting
in yeah getting into the RV life they're
super new to it they just bought this
thing and two months ago they haven't
really yeah they haven't really taken it
anywhere yeah I think they went up at
least one trip their grand goal is to go
from Texas to Calgary Canada oh yeah an
18-day trip yeah and they're gonna take
like small roads and stuff and like
they're not gonna try they're not in a
rush to get there so they're gonna enjoy
the journey there too it made me think
my man if I were to do that if I were to
do a trip like that where would we go I
just like if you had to carve out a
whole month and take a vehicle like this
or take this like borrow this vehicle my
dad was like you can always use this
vehicle if you want you know but I guess
your starting point will always be here
so we have to fly in and then start the
road trip from Texas and then and go to
wherever where would you want to go for
me I would like to do level East Coast
okay so drive from Texas go all the way
down to Miami and then go oh all the way
up
all the way to Maine Florida to Maine
and then like circle around back but
like go like through I don't know just
just create just outline the entire us
well maybe not all the way to the West
Coast we hit La eventually
oh
all right we finally found our site our
site we actually circled around this
campsite the map was poorly drawn
obviously we could not find our parking
spot to save our life circled around for
like I don't know it feels like 40
minutes 45 minutes and then just as we
were about to give up we're like you
know what this spot has some hookups for
the RV thing we're just gonna take it
because we can't find the numbers and
the numbers are all out of order and so
we gave up we were like just pick this
one we drove up to it and lo and behold
number 21.
[Music]
your first camping experience baby oh
yeah I mean yeah yeah trailer
that's true yeah it's true that's true
it's the same thing actually but this
time we drove it here
we drove the whole house here
all right so we missed the
I mean it still looks really cool but we
missed most of the sunset trying to get
here earlier but uh yeah it didn't
happen and we didn't decide on going on
this trip until like last night it's a
last minute trip booking and everything
this morning
oh my gosh look at that smile
you have the best smile Luka
look at those teeth yeah there's teeth
you look older than you actually are no
he looks like one and a half unless he's
two you're aiming a year old baby eleven
months old Bruno
[Music]
I'm checking how level this pet is so
basically this is the highest point of
the right rear and this one I need to
raise my 0.5 which I'm not going to
worry about it and this one has have the
rate 1.5 and 2 inches on that side all
right so I'm learning that one of the
things you gotta do when you do RV life
is when you park it and you're gonna
keep it parked for however long your
stay is you gotta level your vehicle so
you're just pumping something around oh
you're pumping up a mat
[Music]
right a little you zeroed everything out
yep zero everything up
oh it comes out a lot
wow this is cool
yeah I feel safe in here is this the
most expensive toy you've ever bought
yes like an actual noise
spend any more than that for another toy
[Music]
are you gonna cook for us me I don't
know sure let's go for the family
helping no fresh uh
so what are we eating tonight it's steak
can I get two steaks to go please I just
think this is hold up
[Music]
no Daddy hello son hello father hello
boy
she is for the beers
we're about to eat baby look at all this
food bam wanting the steak so badly so
Daddy yes sir we'll cut it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our night in the camper yeah and I just
realized
I just realized that I didn't fully seal
the window last night so the whole time
I was freezing because I was sleeping on
the side so the way that I closed the
window I left like an accidental crack
or I didn't know that it would leave a
crack if I put the lock on the wrong
side because there's like a little Notch
right here and this is where I put all
the locks so there was like a huge crack
in the window where we slept through
that oh sharp baby literally just this
morning I found out why we were freezing
I freaking look
he could have been way more comfortable
I'm sorry baby I felt like I was
starting to get sick or something and
then you were on that side all
comfortable yeah I was like it's kind of
hot over here really yeah I had to like
stick one leg out at one point I was
like yeah it's kind of warm
no I really should have known better I
didn't know
[Music]
that was so close to the family drools
so you don't need them anymore Daddy I'm
already here
let's go have an adventure mama
let's
go
what are you doing all right we're
walking around
the uh like what are you looking at a
shadow all right so we're walking around
the lake it's beautiful out here
it's nice and crisp Luca you're missing
all the sights what are you looking down
for hi baby
hi Luca hi cutie oh you look so cute hey
look we're all wearing Green Jackets
look at all the geese look at all the
geese baby
all right what are you doing what do you
have gloves on all right
it's a Moment of Truth as my dad was
saying we're dealing with her own poop
so we uh you reap what you sow you have
to deal with your own crap deal with
what you crap out
here we go wait before we get to the
nasty look at how cute this little boy
is I don't know if you can see barely
see it oh you can't there he is
cutie hi Luca hey cutie okay so he's
gonna watch his daddy deal with his poop
that's cool so it's like in a in a
container because I've seen Arby's have
like a whole like tube thing or
something yeah way more convenient
all right and unscrew this thing
all right stand back everybody stand
back so you won't pour that thing into
that little thing okay
no no don't drop this oh my God
that's so funny okay to release pressure
okay so you have to do this so put it
over first and then release it right
yeah kind of yeah
stick the whole thing
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
that stinks
the very part's not waterproof oh my
goodness
I totally got a whiff of it all right
ew is it I don't know oh let's see you
guys tell us is there poop in there
oh God I can smell it
uh Waste Management oh heck yeah give me
your own stuff it's okay right yeah I
guess it's better than strangers
this is actually the one part about RV
that I was most interesting really
it's the thing that I would uh to test
the most right I don't want to deal with
it but I guess if I practice secret on
this then I guess I'll be more in kind
of want to do the RV thing yeah like
less of a mystery yeah so this is this
is the big part
[Music]
all right we are doing our New Year's
dinner we have half our dinner here we
have steak we are I finished the lobster
and the the the scallops Luke is having
scallops for the first time he's loving
it look at that all over his face we
already toasted but I I couldn't find my
phone earlier let's do another test for
the vloglet we doing it for the first
time
[Music]
Happy New Year
[Music]
Luca You're Gonna Go Mimi's early but
we're gonna do a countdown okay ready
yeah look at time it's gonna be 20 23
for Luca right now ready ten nine eight
seven six five four three two one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]